Меркель запрошує на роботу. "Зробіть це у Німеччині", тобто працюйте у ФРН.
Такий слоган зустрічі урядовців з бізнесом і профспілками.
Нам бракує кваліфікованих працівників, тож ми зацікавлені, щоб такі робітники приїздили.
Німеччина спрощує працевлаштування для іноземців з країн, які не входять в Євросоюз.
Відповідний закон набере чинності вже цієї весни - з 1 березня 2020 року.
Це відкриває ринок праці не лише для висококваліфікованих працівників з вищою освітою,
але й для представників робітничих професій.
Шукачам роботи дозволяється приїхати до Німеччини на пів року.
Але не по "безвізу".
Біометричний паспорт і безвізовий режим між Україною і ЄС не дають права на роботу.
Потрібна спеціальна віза для пошуку роботи - Visum zur Arbeitsplatzsuche.
Вона видається у посольстві ФРН у Києві або інших німецьких консульських установах.
Для отримання візи потрібно документально підтвердити знання з німецької мови.
Якщо не володієте німецькою - обґрунтувати письмово, чому ці знання
не є необхідними для вашої професії.
Обов’язково також підтвердити фінансування на весь період перебування у Німеччині.
З розрахунку 853 євро на місяць.
Тобто на пів року треба мати щонайменше 5118 євро.
Адже жити в Німеччині весь період пошуку роботи доведеться за свій рахунок.
Шукачі роботи протягом свого перебування у ФРН
не матимуть права на отримання жодних соціальних виплат.
Як підтвердити фінансування - позичити гроші при потребі чи взяти кредит -
це вже кожен вирішує для себе.
Необхідно також пред'явити медстраховку на пів року, укласти яку в Україні теж не є проблемою.
Натомість одна з найбільших перепон - визнання дипломів.
Для тих, хто має вищу освіту, ця процедура врегульована в рамках болонського процесу,
який значно спростив порівняння освітніх ступенів у різних країнах Європи.
А от для тих, хто має професійно-технічну освіту,
ситуація складніша і пов'язана з додатковими витратами.
Справа в тому, що у Німеччині так звана дуальна освіта.
Це коли студент працює за фахом уже під час навчання.
І тому закордонна освіта часто не прирівнюється до німецької.
Але уряд ФРН обіцяє посприяти спрощенню визнання отриманої в інших країнах профосвіти.
У свою чергу роботодавці теж зацікавлені всіляко допомагати новим працівникам -
у вивченні німецької мови, пошуку житла та адаптації дожиття у ФРН
з її доволі бюрократичною системою.
Ще один важливий нюанс.
Роботу можна буде шукати лише за спеціальністю, яка підтверджена дипломом.
Тобто хочеш працювати в Німеччині електриком - має бути відповідний диплом.
Або якщо є вакансія на покрівельника і шукач роботи охоче взявся б за це,
але навчався на сантехніка, то його швидше за все попри нестачу робочих рук не візьмуть.
Якщо вдасться знайти роботу, то відомство у справах іноземців у ФРН
подовжить піврічну візу без виїзду в Україну.
Важливий нюанс: возз’єднання родини з шукачем роботи неможливе -
лише після працевлаштування і видачі відповідного дозволу на перебування.
У ФРН бракує робочих рук, адже німецьке суспільство старішає.
Серед тих професій, де є найбільше вакансій -
медсестри і доглядальниці, IT-фахівці, електротехніки і металурги.
Про те, скільки саме робочих рук має бути залучено, щоб покрити дефіцит кадрів, точно невідомо.
Але мова йде про сотні тисяч незайнятих робочих місць.
За різними підрахунками, компенсувати нестачу робочих рук вдасться, якщо в Німеччину
щорічно приїжджатимуть 260 тисяч мігрантів.